message pour tous les amoureux des
chiens dans nos auditeurs ou même pour
les chiens qui nous écoutent pour les
chiens qui amateurs de podcasts ou
halder ailleurs font des produits pour
chiens la nourriture pour chien next
level produits pour chiens ces éco
responsable c'est à bord de protéine
alternative c'est une entreprise d'ici
n'ont ils pas dire jeunes qui tout se
fait par une équipe peut être d'ici que
je dire par des jeunes passionnés de
nourriture pour chien et offre plusieurs
choses en fait qui offre des gâteries à
base de grilles on y offre des gâteries
pour vos chiens à base de protéines
végétales donc vegan comme ont
communément appelée vegan donc c'est à
base d'algues de gaspésie ainsi que de
pulpe de jus récupérer il collabore avec
la compagnie loupe qui font des jeux que
vous voyez en fait dans les épiceries
qui réutilise déjà les fruits qui sont
gaspillées par les commerces à des
grandes surfaces
puis ensuite ils filent leur pulpe
houser ailleurs fait rien qui se perd
ses 360
encore une fois et ils font aussi de la
nourriture à base d'insectes pour vos
chiens et de la nourriture à base de
poisson donc vraiment comme des tentes
aux knicks l'erreur en termes de
produits laitiers l'aurait tuée puis on
a un code promo pour vous autres en fait
ces 20 % de rabais sur toute la boutique
en ligne fait qu on le sait que dans nos
autres stores ya des gens qui ont des
chiens ou des chats vous en ce moment
vous comme vous achetez en faire de
pleins de compagnie pourquoi pas
encourager une compagnie québécoise qui
avec 1 20 % de rabais en faisant le code
promo s f 20 pour 20% de rabais on
encourage locale puis vos chiens vont
adorer ça je dirais même que six a pas
de chiffre puisse considérer acheter un
chien pour pouvoir acheter du wild
weasel tellement que c'est de la bonne
bouffe s'en va c'est sacré
le podcast sur le stress etc soigner le
pied c'est prouvé que ça diminue le
stress de flatter un beau petit chien
donc je considérais vraiment l'option
est tout à fait donc allé voir sur leur
site internet mon chien sauve le monde
point ca
puis on n'a pas assez de compagnies
comme ceux qui sont socialement active
fait que mercy la gagne vous voulez
faire votre propre podcast loué le
studio sf ici tout est là les micros
l'équipement on y colle à la technique
qui vient avec le package
alors pour faire vos podcasts c'est ici
que ça se passe hier c'est un service
clé en main vous avez juste à préparer
votre contenu venir vous asseoir puis
maximum 48 heures après votre
enregistrement vous avez ça dans votre
boîte email
montez mixer tout le kit juste besoin de
vous concentrer sur la qualité de votre
contenu fake pour plus d'information
pour ça écrivait noix sans filtre
podcast à commercial gmail.com oui une
production du f
[Musique]
bienvenue au sans fil que le podcast où
on parle de ce qu'on veut que nos
invités dates ci-dessous perche quant à
moi de me plante
cette semaine on a reçu rémi quirion le
scientifique en chef du québec c'est le
chef ces chefs des scientifiques de
toutes les scientifiques telle chirurgie
mais c'était vraiment passionnant c'est
un geek un parcours incroyable grâce
scientifique qui a travaillé surtout
dans les neurosciences maintenant ce
qu'il veut ce post le scientifique en
chef qui comme un titre que plusieurs
fonctions dont il explique tout ça dans
le podcast et où tout vous expliquer ce
geste ait droit à une discussion autour
de la science rend passionnante on ne
parlait aussi de deux de nouvelles
technologies qui est vraiment
complètement incroyable on a parlé
d'environnement de parler de la pandémie
des vaccins on a parlé aussi de ce qui
était sa spécialité son sujet 2
cherche c'était vraiment une grande
rencontre avec un grand esprit un grand
scientifique c'était un honneur de
recevoir mois puis c'est pas de cas cela
ce n'est pas de casque nous intéresse
beaucoup
de toute évidence vous intéresse
beaucoup aussi on veut essayer d'avoir
plus de scientifiques en fait on trouve
que c'est vraiment pertinent comme on
discute avec rémi durand le le podcast
je pense que de faire le lien entre la
population et la science et les
chercheurs c'est vraiment une mission
qu'on qu'on veut donner au centre le
podcast à écouter
abonnez vous à nos jeunes un peu vous
abonner à notre pétrole c'est ce qu'on
fait un après chaud après tous les shows
meilleure façon de nous encourager aussi
on ya beaucoup de nouveaux membres
pétrone dernièrement fait qu' on vous
salue d'ailleurs puis sinon ça sans plus
attendre
bonne écoute podcast
[Musique]
puis donc bonjour bienvenue merci
beaucoup d'être le fait très plaisir
très plaisir de avec vous là on ne reçut
olivier bernard puis c'est lui qui nous
ont mentionné que existait un
scientifique en chef pour le mans qui
nous écoutent rapidement puis aussi pour
nous quel est le rôle mais ton club
allemand du scientifique en chef
oui ici au québec c'est un peu différent
d'autres régions du monde scientifique
en chef c'est un modèle britannique
donc ça a été développé en angleterre
dans les années 60 dont j'ai longtemps
mais c'est vraiment modèle je dirais
plus commonwealth
donc c'était les premiers par la suite
du l'australie a eu une nouvelle ronde
ils ont aussi à d'autres différents
endroits dans la francophonie y en a pas
des marches autres maintenant il ya le
canada l'a fait c'est un peu bling mona
nemer mais sinon mieux francophone très
très très peu et le modèle québécois est
un peu différent donc le rôle en général
des scientifiques en chef
c'était un aviseur au gouvernement donc
on donne des avis au gouvernement tous
qui tous la science la recherche
l'innovation donc ça couvre très très
très large et moi ici au québec la façon
dont sont organisés je suis sous le
ministère de l'économie de l'innovation
ok donc avec un pierre fils de goetmals
à bouger au cours depuis juin parce
qu'après 10 ans maintenant c'est le cas
les gouvernements changent vous restera
en place a souri
c'est un c'est pas une domination il ya
un an que ça change lié maintenant il ya
aussi un genre de poste équivalent aux
états unis et quand le nouveau président
ou la nouvelle présidente est nommé ben
alors fait place nette il faut chercher
de nouveaux bancs moi-je sur andrew
quatrième gouvernement et trois couleurs
le parti québécois et la coalition
avenir québec et on est resté toujours
resté en place un peu avec la même
équipe mais on était des flocons et l
économie d'innovation comme au début
quand je suis arrivé ce développement
économique ça s'appelait par la suite
ans elle passe à l'éducation et passe à
l'enseignement supérieur à cahors on
avait assez comme ça nos cartes
d'affaires ont changé cette fin
dans le rôle des visas aux gouvernements
soucier des rôles importants et
finalement avec le temps c'est beaucoup
beaucoup la confiance de part et d'autre
que les élus ou les hauts fonctionnaires
mais les députés les ministres y en
avoir confiance en toi donc très souvent
c'est pas une question d'écrire des
thèses de doctorat c'est vraiment très
court et l'autorité et appelle pisa
qu'est ce que tu penses de sow les
cheveux ras le sol à mama display need
et les neurosciences au cerveau une
maladie mentale mais je connais pas
toujours une chance un club j'appelle
des collègues ou des gens que je connais
dans le réseau qu'est ce que vous pensez
de la question où est en général
lorsqu'on une question de me nice
encore là c'est pas de maîtrise ou un
doctorat n'était pas là quatre heures
après midi il veut la réponse le
lendemain matin je me rappelle une fois
dans notre gouvernement d'appel de
munich ce qui me dit battoir rugby
qu'est ce que tu penses du pitbull la
période où il y avait un pitbull qui
avait
tu es un enfant je pense à des percées à
deux amis qui veut dire hey dans
certains quartiers de montréal
oui on accepte football non l'autre
l'acceptent pas il y avait dans une
virée musicale heureusement vers atar
étudiée au niveau du gouvernement mais
quel genre de règles ont peu à voir si
on doit avoir des règles parce que ça
devient très compliqué et plusieurs des
idées et l'uil du d'histoire ça marche
pas moi si j'étais la rue à côté j'aurai
droit lg pas droit moi je connais rien
et janssen 6 à 5
elle est le maire qu'est-ce que vous
parle ce soit il on donne les avis abc
souvent sais pas je vous devriez faire
ça c'est pour avoir abaissé par la suite
se décide sur la base de considérations
je dirais plus citoyenne la science mais
aussi une décision qui est politique et
citoyen qui est ce aussi un rôle
important
l'autre aussi que aussi le modèle
québécois ge président les trois fonds
de recherche du québec
donc mes trois conseils subventionnaires
du québec donc pour des jeunes qui font
par exemple des études à la maîtrise au
doctorat le post date les jeunes
chercheurs nous on supporte beaucoup de
bourses d'excellence
donc ça on fait beaucoup ça on se porte
des réseaux de recherche on supporte
bessat en prie instituts de recherche
donc ça aussi c'est un rôle important
prise des trois conseils
d'administration j'ai comme pdg des
trois fonds dans les grands secteurs
secteur de la santé le secteur qu'on
appelle nature et technologie sur les
sciences pures les mathématiques et le
génie est l'autre secteur qui on appelle
société culture ceci sciences sociales
si on semaine l'art la culture
l'économie la gestion
pas mal tout ça pour ça qu'on fait à peu
près à peu près tout et b ce qu'on
essaie de faire en plus depuis toujours
en poste pour les grands défis de
société
oui on a besoin d' expertise là par
exemple climat on a besoin de quelqu'un
capable mesurer climat mais ça on sait
faire quand même se pose en vrai avec la
de mettre des gens qui sont experts en
expertise là dedans avec des géographes
avec des personnes en santé avec des
personnes en acceptabilité sociale de
plus social sciences humaines nous
finalement le problème maintenant
souvent des changements climatiques
c'est plutôt de ça veut dire quoi pour
moi - pour moi dans ma rue que ça change
la vie ça fait peut-être quelque chose
de nouveau appelé nations unies ou du
fédéral que ça veut dire pour faire le
pont entre ces séances l'afssa s'est
vraiment c'est que nous on a personne au
grand défi de société dans notre jargon
c'est de la recherche inter sectorielle
revient donc l'autre mais quelqu'un en
ginibre exemple avec quelqu'un qui est
en sciences sociales et au début il se
regarde un peu quand on est chiante
faïence mal mais c'est pas de ma
mâchoire leur d'ilona anglais français
c'est relativement facile mais quand
nous là dedans c'est vraiment un qui
parle le mandarin et l'hôtel france
moins qu'au début des premières autres
qu'est-ce que je perds mon temps avec
ces gens là j'apprends rien comprennent
auriez trouvé mes bêtises on met ce tube
est éloquent tout commence à comprendre
à ok si je fais cela je vais être
capable d'aller beaucoup plus loin dans
ma programmation de recherche
donc ça aussi longtemps fait de plus en
plus ce genre de programme là qui sont
peut-être un peu moins ciblé leurs une
question très pointue et précise mais
peut-être plus quelque chose d'un peu
plus la taxe on en haut mais ça c'est
son téléphone et les jeunes aiment
beaucoup sont aussi là parce qu'avec a
maintenant avec les réseaux sociaux avec
l'internet et tout ça si l'expert est à
singapour mme du contrat car cinq
éprouve ce tome moi quand j'ai fait mes
études
c'était plus ok tu as maigri on essaie
de voir ce qui est amaigri mais
maintenant c'est global fait ils veulent
avoir des équipes très
multidisciplinaire et ça va ça nous on
essaie d'aider le plus possible de ce
côté là du d'après moi c'est un peu
l'université de demain parce que c'est
nouveau seul en fait ce que c'est une
problématique justement d'adam dans les
champs expertise le manque de
communication entre entre chacun d'eux
chaque hémisphère loup c'est assez
courant que chamakh et département va
parler un hôte le fais ici c'est pas si
courant que ça parce que c'est certain
lorsqu'on on devient expert très près
sur le mais les hammers a peut-être sur
le climat la façon dont on est formé et
on va de plus en plus spécialisés de
plus en plus pointues
donc moi je disais souvent mais mes
étudiants dans mon laboratoire ou à
l'hôpital de glace là lorsque vous allez
défendre votre thèse de doctorat sur une
question particulier là là vous allez
tout savoir sur y un nom devient
tellement on est dessus que pour
quelques heures
quant à la montre une personne qui
reconnaît plus sur ce sujet là quelques
heures c'est le mot clé c'est beau ça
bouge il faut préparer la liste puis
c'est la prière d'autres choses changent
quand même relativement rapidement et
après ça d'être obligé presque de l'hôte
était tellement pointu de revenus pas de
revenir en arrière mais de s'exposer à
d'autres thématiques d'autres
problématiques pour élargir un peu des
champs de connaissances mais tu as
appris une méthode sûre après la méthode
scientifique sur 7 permet de faire c'est
un petit peu un coût souvent après un
doctorat ce que tu fais tu pour défendre
ce qu'on appelle des études
postdoctorales ils ne savent souvent
dans une thématique un peu un peu
différente sujet de thèse est là quand
tu appelés pour des emplois surtout si
tu restes en mieux academy dans les
universités ou les collèges mais là tu
as rêvé d'un département de botanique
paris grand pilote et collègues vont
tout est à peu près du même membres qui
vont te dire de rester dans ce monde un
toit de ce foutu train sur le nom d'une
renommée en botanique commence pas trop
tôt à parler avec les gens qui sont en
chimie le père pendu avec un con on est
un peu tous en silo donc maintenant ce
qu'on essaie de faire c'est de
décloisonner an de plus tout seul et
sans avec le l'étang de l'école parce
que j'ai bien ça permet de créer des
nouveaux programmes y en a un qu'on
appelle rodas et c'est ce que je disais
aux collègues et aux collègues
chercheurs le je veux avoir vos
meilleures idées
les idées les plus folles en général
pour des subventions de recherche en
tout et où j'ai très très très carrée
loin tu devrais dire je fais ça pour
faire sauter d'objets très carré là ses
désirs non je veux pas voir cela je veux
pas si on prend une analogie debise
barrent l'horizon que je pourrais me
rends premier but nous coûte 5 l'usure
cuit jordi montréjeau en trois manches
et joue de retraits au bâton en place
mais la science ça devrait être ça
marche
aussi dans 90% des cas c'est corey et
quand ça marche pas notre jour de
différent et que l'on met des gens dans
le programme audace vraiment qui vient
de discipline très différents et
lorsqu'il nous présente le résultat est
vraiment ça chante ça change un peu les
modèles fait que ça c'est très important
c'est fascinant j'ai plein de questions
mais juste avant on était très mauvaise
autres ce que vous voulez quelque chose
à bord n'ont jamais si on va le
programme audace et ça m'intéresse
beaucoup d'en apprendre plus est ce
qu'il ya des choses qui sont que des
gros coups de circuit dernièrement con
qu'on sait qu'on connaît qu'on a vu
passer ce qui ce qui est intéressant il
sort ça nous a surpris on pensait même
époque qu'on aurait ce genre de
propositions là il ya une dame une
fermière agricultrices de la région de
granby qui produit du foie gras le
gavage habituel des canards et des oies
plat l'avez entendu parler du programme
audace à la radio au volant radio qu'on
avait pas de s'amender puis elle allait
attendre vu que restaurants à new yok
utilisait du foie gras mais qui était
pas produit par garage selon les
techniques habituelles mais plutôt le
comportement habituel de l'animal parce
qu'avant partir pour les grandes
migrations
ils vont se gaver pendant suffisamment
d'énergie qu'elle appelle le
restaurateur new york est pas dit j'ai
entendu dire que tu utilisais du foie
gras dha du monde en gav est forcément
puis lui oui mais moi je connais rien
attendre
j'utilise comme ça tu devrais essayer de
contacter des chercheurs peut-être au
québec et voir s'il ya de l'intérêt
la beauté de la chose d'une dame qui est
très dynamique là elle a appris un des
chercheurs
un auchan montréal ici au centre
hospitalo universitaires en
endocrinologie donc les ombres et la
beauté de la chose c'est que cherche un
report accroché parce que quand on a
commencé sur youtube
elle promet un peu bizarre mais
peut-être quelque chose je l'aï
finalement parlé sont finalement ce sont
convaincus qu'il avait peut-être quelque
chose l'a fait lui parler avec des
collègues du courtier radiologie passe
maintenant avec des techniques très
avancées de radiologie on peut voir le
dépôt de lipides nom de grèce sont dans
l'air dans le foie d'environ 10 bat
peut-être qu'on pourrait faire ça aussi
un spécialiste du comportement animal
qu'on peut demander des oies et des
canards et ont fait la demande
et cette dame là lorsque nous présente
les preuves le projet de recherche
c'est fabuleux leur petit sachet
s'agissait de deux vélos l'animal bon je
prépare pour quitter bientôt pour la
migration
comment identifier que s'ils tentent si
on veut le sacrifie par son poids est
vraiment engorgé degré espère
naturellement nous on fait ça avec le
radiologue est tout sauf sexy quand même
c'est quand même assez fabuleux d'auxi
venue d'une citoyenne ce même pas venue
d'un chercheur texan il ya quelques
jours ce look est quand même intéressant
dans l'autre c'est très différent
les cancers les cancers du village quant
au cancer du sein
souvent quand ils font beaucoup de
chirurgie duplass t'es tu te reconnais
plus ou moins dans le miroir avec toute
sa personnalité il y avait beaucoup de
problématiques l'odeur de remise en
question de personnalité de santé
mentale est ce donc là les chercheurs
aussi ont suggéré il ya des des
plasticiens des ingénieurs des médecins
que nous aurions des chirurgiens avec
les patients et c'est une mixité des
patients qui ont pris le leadership là
dedans
tiens en parlant leurs collègues en
zambie nous pour nous c'est intéressant
avec l'oeil en dépit même développé une
petite compagnie qui en terme de deux
façons de faire les nouveaux visages
tenir compte du peuple la sensibilité
humaine
du village de la personne qui soit dans
le miroir qui ont développé une petite
compagnie reliés à sa collaboration de
l'école technologie supérieure
ici à montréal et le chum le fixe aussi
c'est assez serez paris serait pas comme
de quoi quand qu'on met son expertise à
contribution chacun on arrive à des
résultats qui sont prêts mais je pense
que du côté environnement changement
climatique objectifs de développement
durable ça va être très très important
d'amener des des experts de différentes
disciplines travaillent ensemble est
aussi d'amener le citoyen 3 languedoc
citoyens partenaires on eu de plus en
plus aussi de programmes qu'on appelle
de science participative où le projet de
recherche est proposée par par le
citoyen ne puisse se produire je te
regarde mon engagement serait marc se
rapprocher de la société sont tout en
bas de climat ça ça touche à toutes les
sphères de la vie pratiquement pile ça
concerne tout le monde en fait parce
qu'on est toutes nous tous ensemble sur
une même planète qui tue qui change donc
faux chacun met son nez c'est peut-être
dire eu plein de côté un peu plus
compliquée la pandémie mais peut-être
tandis des bons côtés de la pandémie
soeur 106 ebook ou les gens à la science
la façon de faire de la science
on ne travaillait encore davantage en
équipe on voit veux te développement des
vaccins c'était très très très rapide
mais ce parce que cette pandémie loeb et
là ça touche tout le monde quelqu'un
peut mourir d'un grand mère dont et en
barges bodrogi mexès a touché tout le
monde donc maintenant on a cette voie ce
qu'on a appris ou jeu qu'on n'a pas de
cette pandémie là est-ce qu'on peut
utiliser stratégie un peu semblable du
côté de l'environnement et des
changements climatiques
tant que c'est de l'amener aussi un peu
plus près de tous et chacun alors parce
que sinon ça paraît distant sont
prohibitifs très télé crise les deux ces
deux crises longues aux points communs
une qui qui qui qui qui se déroule très
rapidement mais le virus b tandis que
des climats c'est sur du plus long terme
sauf que justement le
ce qu'ils ont en commun c'est qu'on y
participe tous mais on est tous touchés
par ce lundi donc il faut tout enlever
une vis qui justement le plus on attend
avant de réagir à cette crise du climat
là le plus difficile c'est de traverser
comme celle on a à se dérouler ses
soucis très long après ce mois d effet
on voit le taf est beaucoup plus tendre
et c'est ça qui est un peu un défi pour
ce que nous sommes certainement biaiser
le midi pour sortir de ce genre de
situation là c'est la recherche et la
science avec la pandémie on le voit là
oui on peut rester confiné un certain
boutin même pas pour 15 ans quant au
besoin de nouvelles façons de faire on a
besoin de vaccin avec les changements
climatiques ou six pour trouver des
façons différent parce que prenantes les
deux ont même oublié on parle de façon
de hans ri mais même en termes
d'étiologie de cluj 1 probablement que
le fait qu'avec les changements
climatiques la biodiversité on en perd
et cetera et cetera
mais pour moi qui ai eu certaines y ait
là dedans aussi qu'on exploite aussi une
nature qui sont censés les tonnages
source et sa grande exploit sur exploit
triplette faut trouver d'autres façons
il en parle de plus en plus le
d'économie circulaire de temps consommé
jeter mais dès le début une téléphone
seulement par exemple à une fois qu'on
qu'on ne veut plus de thon seront
recyclés parce que beaucoup d éléments
là donc peuvent être recyclés mieux que
de jeter bien l'élan fruits red sox est
pour l'heure du conte alimentation
pourrait presque tout risque lui aussi
de plus en plus des équipements qui se
mettent sur place nous on finance aussi
là dedans l'économie circulaire et ça
c'est encore une fois ça besoin
d'experts dans l'environnement mais ça a
besoin d'experts gillis a besoin mais
comme elle en sciences sociales en
économie dans toutes sortes de secteurs
fac sont aussi là il ya bout les jeunes
sont très intéressés par sont aussi la
nouvelle génération peut avoir des
programmes de recherche costaud dans ces
secteurs donne donc son voeu où aller
davantage là dedans
ils sont très certainement que c'est
moi les nouveaux programmes ça nous ça
nous stimule beaucoup et je pense que le
gouvernement comprend de mieux en mieux
aussi ce qu'on essaie de faire de ce
côté là
ils l'ont vu avec avec la pandémie autre
point seul troisième mandat est à
l'international donc lié à
l'international ou même de nos équipes
de recherche au niveau international un
volet qu'on appelle de la diplomatie
scientifique très souvent la science
pour ouvrir des portes là comme le boson
de higgs
finalement ça genève les gens qui ont
découvert ça faisait longtemps que
importante ce qui était bien avec ça ne
pose pas le seul puis ce genre de
particules à point les gens qui ont
découvert est un chercheur qui vient de
l'iran quitte à côté du palestinien
quitte à cause de l'israélien sont donc
là la science rimasson d'un outil de
diplomatie sont utilisent de plus en
plus soulignait quant à eux tous les
maris des partenariats avec palestine et
de dernier point je devrais dans mon
mandat
et on ne parle un peu déjà mais c'est
science et société on sait comment
parler davantage la science dans notre
société des réseaux comme ici mais aussi
les plus traditionnels peut-être je
pense est important d'abord que le
chercheur les chercheuses one peu plus
sur la place publique
d'abord en jargon plus simple aussi et
d'expliquer surtout la méthode si on ne
sait pour moi c'est pour les riches
toujours le dans la presse est plutôt là
la méthode scientifique et comment
embassies un argumentaire s'y développer
l'esprit c'est que c'est le très très
important j'étais justement en fait on a
parlé avant d'être en on l'a finalement
le t2 que ph et moi on n'attaque pas mal
elle trouvait des bulgares a vu quatre
scientifiques pour venir ici parce que
s'il y est clairement un appétit pour ce
pur pour le pour la science pour les
données probantes supplie gens sont pas
intéressés que je crois qu'on fait des
podcasts dans ces thèmes là les vendeurs
se tient sauf qu'ils sont difficiles à
trouver ces scientifiques qui font aussi
du public sont ce parallèle qui sait qui
est qui et qui sont prêts
à sortir de leur labo d'une faute à date
heure pour venir parler et que comme
vous le faites aujourd'hui de cépie
justement t on parler que des reçus de
quelques semaines tu es sonia lupien et
puis à chaque fois que j'ai des
discussions comme ça avec des gens de
sciences le comme vous comme sonia je me
dis crime est tellement de choses qu'on
sait que l'humanité ces tickets que que
les études qu'elle a recherches ont été
rendues loin mais ça savoir le t il se
rend pas il sera difficilement la mare
cyprès fu chi tu des fois on est 30 rami
ont jamais on se met à parler de sujets
ou ou assassinés sur quelque chose puis
10,3 je me dis il ya quelqu'un quelque
part qui fait son docteur la tuque il
faudrait que tellement de choses que
quand vous quittez vie je sais tu es
avec avec sonia ya tellement de choses
sur le stress que je reconnaissais pas
les mouches pensé que c'était quelque
chose d'abstrait un peu lequel sur 100
dans ton ventre mais non un sit in
harmony celle ci celle là celle là ça
fonctionne comme ça sécrétée par sas à
seppi ça devient super club paye plus
d'espèces de débat le débat flou des
personnes qui connaissent à moitié sud
cpie classique de la science de prouver
le type par la méthode scientifique
or presque de tout doute raisonnable que
c'est le même cas ça fonctionne c'est
prix bien plus c'est une découverte
montréalaise mot stress vienne le
professeur dit notamment dans les années
40 qui commençait sa carrière à miguel
notre parti à l'universel montréal et
c'est lui qui a donné ce terme là si
elle était aux états unis par des
histoires de récompenses scientifiques
aussi quand même
façon de faire une machine en rdc pour
moi qui ont un prix nobel
ici au canada ou au québec bas prix
nobels arrive comme ça on s'est mis aux
arrêts pour bâtir une carrière - et avec
sa souris et d'autres prix mais en
scellier et c'est vraiment lui qui
définit le terme du bon stress du
mauvais stress un peu comme sonia vous a
parlé avec un objectif dans ce journal
tout seul effet au cerveau qui était un
des très grands pionniers de ce côté là
du voile et puis en préparant pour le
reste avec sonia j'avais une avant tendu
par les danses alliés parce qu'il y
avait jamais eu une vidéo sur youtube
parce que sonia à parler justement de ce
monsieur py elle disait qui à son époque
lui il faisait ce aller dans le public
puis vulgate grippe ce qui est elle trop
mais mal vu à l'époque de faire ce qui
l'amena à comprendre pourquoi puis brava
prat la question pourquoi ça serait mal
vu puisque celle là encore aujourd'hui
jusque là c'est pas nécessairement mal
vu aujourd'hui il on travaille là-dessus
aussi de notre côté là c'est de
reconnaître ce genre d'activités là bas
parce qu alors qu'un jeune prof qui
vient d'être engagé par l'université
quelconque et au début c'est sur cette
démarrer l'équipe est productif et la
compétition est relativement solide doit
tant qu'on doit être productif on doit
produire assez rapidement et très
souvent lorsque tu étais value est là
pour des promotions l'université encore
tété va lever beaucoup sur des
publications combien tôt une publication
dans quel type de revue scientifique
après vous considérez un peu
l'enseignement non seulement tu es
affaires de mini cours à l'université et
en troisième lieu tout ce qu'on appelle
les autres activités
enfin quit est allé dans une conférence
à chambre de commerce
ma histoire c'est good as marsa mais
c'est pas ça compte pas vraiment donc
lorsqu'on est sept frères et son
changement de culture ses désirs ses des
activités aussi important que des
publications scientifiques
donc vraiment de vulgariser la recherche
la séance où la science en général pour
cimenter résultat tout est là c'est très
important et on doit valoriser sa
davantage et lorsque des chercheurs
applique pour des subventions chine où
les perles et comité de pairs qui revoit
les demandes doivent en tenir compte
dans ses puces et pour seulement 10 à
uyo fait ça en plus non faut vraiment
mettre des points qu'on m'a dit on met
des points pour les projets et pour les
publications donc on n'est pas les seuls
à faire ça maintenant mettre de plus en
plus on s'en voir ce pour stimuler les
jambes sincèrement tout le monde qui
veut le faible c'est correct mais ceux
qui veulent le faire
on devrait reconnaître ses activités de
très grands de très grande valeur et en
plus de ça pour moi
souvent c'est les subventions de
recherche que l'on reçoit mais c'est
vous d'ailleurs deux taxes c'est ça
vienne jeu ça vient d'un grand public
c'est patent autant dans 80 des plaines
sous pour faire de la recherche
taka de redonner à la société en
expliquer un peu le stress en expliquant
les changements climatiques
l'alzheimer ou que ce soit je pense et
on doit redonner mais c'est certain que
pour nous pour les organisations qui
finance la recherche
ça doit être mieux reconnu cela doit
être mieux reconnu par les universités
aussi c'est intéressant de voir le de ce
point de vue là parce que mettons du
point de vue de la population en général
on dirait qu'un mur tient entre la
communauté scientifique slash
universitaire et la population en
général qui pour essayer de rendre ce
mur le plus c'est quoi le terme de lieu
les vases communicateurs pour faire
communiquer les vagues dans le fond
c'est sûr que ça prend un pont parce que
sinon ça fait juste accentuer le fossé
entre les deux groupes de personnes puis
l'espèce de 10 dès que la communauté de
chercheurs et universitaires un peu
hautain père gagnent un peu le monde de
loin dans leur tour d'ivoire avec
laurent leur béchard dit c'est cette
image là c'est sur kaka doit absolument
être déconstruit
vous parliez tout à l'heure de la
méthode scientifique et une bonne
représentation de commandes la
population et pas au courant de la
méthode scientifique c'est quand qu'on
la voit se dérouler en temps réel comme
durant la covin le monde sont pas prêts
à accepter que à qui l'on s'est trompé
on fait un pas en avant on a fait un
arrière de pas l'avant un à l'arrière le
monde voit ce design les scientifiques
savent pas de quoi ils parlent
ils reculent ils se contredisent mais en
fait la méthode scientifique
c'est un peu ce que tu fais des essais
il ya des affaires que tu rates tu
réalises qu'une nouvelle information
tuque respect si la population était au
courant de la méthode scientifique +16
erreurs le du gouvernement de la santé
publique
il verrait ça comme un avancement ou une
nouvelle connaissance qui vient
d'arriver en fait non 12 a été été
incroyable avec la non travaillées tout
le monde
des gens qu'à la santé publique les élus
premier ministre depuis depuis le mois
de mars
incroyable mais à toute beauté de côté
sciences quand même
non non on connaissait rien si quelqu'un
m'avait dit même que je suis moi je ne
participe à plusieurs discussions là on
va avoir un vaccin avant de l'année
avant la fin de l'année verra j'en vois
pas se prendre au moins un bon bout de
temps plus que savent donc lorsqu'on a
fait et on espère qu'on va regarder ça
ce qu'on a mis en commun vous collaborez
énormément au niveau mondial bonjour au
québec au québec beaucoup mais aussi à
l'international pour aller le plus
rapidement possible la séquence de virus
quand l'autre la république et tout le
monde la demande de la voix
les chinois l'ont soutien extrêmement
contrainte futur dans notre société
aujourd'hui le tout tout tout devienne
ainsi qu'on appelle la science ouverte
donc on espère qu'on a fait un bon bout
là dedans parce qu'on connaissait rien
ils sont un peu on utilise souvent
l'analogie l'ascum construire un avion
en vol au début car plus virus qui est
un peu particulier
on connaissait vraiment pas et là pour
le pour les élus en particulier
ils doivent décider là car une fois
c'est une question de semaines mais
maintenant que ce que je fais avec ce
fardeau avec l'autre donne des avis qui
sont basées sur une certaine science
mais encore la science que je dirais
molle parce qu'on ne peut lutter
vraiment de la belle idée au complet ce
qui fait qu'ils wii u des allers retours
comme ça des âmes en c est sûr qu est ce
que moi j'ai beaucoup aimé c'est
vraiment les liens très très fort les
collaborations très forte des équipes à
travers le monde
nous on veut que ça continue la même
chose pour les défis encore plus grand
sur vire falloir apprendre pandémie le
puits qu'est-ce que fonctionner pour
garder ce ensuite le tir le sinistre a
fait état tout moment par en mars
dernier je me trompe aupic vous disiez
d'accès d'après moi dans un an un an et
demi on risque d'avoir ce [ __ ] c'est
fou que ça dit plus à pedrena en plus
dans un monde où est
en général on s'est toujours plus longs
tout début le confinement on pensait que
ça serait vraiment moins long que
j'aurais plus long plus bas et que les
vaccins plus rapide pour les comparer et
puis on espère que si d'ici quelques
mois au moins la majorité des personnes
devront être vaccinés et je dois dire
que je suis quand même ici au québec on
est chanceux québec canada
l'ouverture du citoyen des failles
comprend pas nécessairement tous les
détails de la méthode scientifique ou de
la science mais une grande ouverture et
beaucoup d'intérêt sont nés quand même
chanceux par rapport à d'autres sociétés
où les gens dotés nommément non crois
pas c'est qu'on est quand même et des
émissions comme celle ci puis on a là
des médias plus traditionnels
ils ont quand même beaucoup pour une
petite communauté quand même quelques
millions a dit souvent on n'est même pas
la banlieue de tokyo où toute la
population
ils sont nés chanceux et de ce côté-là
d'avoir des façons de fac est de plus en
plus de chercheurs soit sur la place
publique
quand on sait pense pas c'est pendant
tout essayé de faire une histoire qui
l'a par la suite baisse avant de revenir
dans faire ça c'est mieux de tribus de
dire qu'on sait pas mais on l'a pas
quand même le doute les 70 minorité
bruyante ce qui qu'il s'oppose à la
science au consensus puisque puis au
vaccin évidemment mais est-ce que tu
aimais tant moi j'ai des gens proches de
moi qu'ils trichent pour contre les
vaccins mais y est a été fait rapidement
ce qu'ont pu savoir à 100% qu'il ya pas
d effet sur le long terme si comment
qu'on fait pour savoir si dans dix ans
je peux avoir un effet secondaire qui va
apparaître le vaccin lucho est ce que
c'est quelque chose qui existe sexy
propos du tout si je pense que pour les
vaccins on connaît quand même beaucoup
world skies la façon dont cet effet une
technologie un peu différent mais les
gens ont pris aussi les bases de
connaissances de vaccins et l appui
aussi beaucoup de touristes entre
guillemets parce qu'en général on fait
étape numéro un on fait deux ont fait 3
enfin quand on fait ça que ça prend du
talent lorsqu'il fait ce qu'on a fait ce
qu'on a fait en séquentiel en ordre dit
ok ça marche
je commence lords avant d'avoir et la
production de vaccins en général ça
arrive la tête au bout des étapes
d'essais cliniques soit 35,6 envers sa
et l'autre commence à produire ton ex 1
donc là les compagnies avec les
gouvernements dur commence à les
produire tout si jamais ça s'avère
qu'ils sont beaux bonbons votre maître
sa poubelle mais finalement il s'arrête
et que l'on trouvait des années aussi
avec cela n'est qu'une façon de faire un
peu différent et on espère maintenant
qu'on peut regarder cette façon là aussi
parce qu'on en aura d'autres pandémies
malraux du mal on va être obligé d'avoir
d'autres vaccins je pense que oui une
certaine inquiétude mine du côté public
mais je pense que l'excellence les
façons de faire les essais cliniques
tour et et retraités leur geste était un
peu partout à travers le monde
la hausse est certain qu'on a vu plus
tout ce qui est plus foncée nouvelle
complot ça il y en avait avant
ouais mais c'est surtout avec la
pandémie l'os ça c'était encore mis à
l'avant scène encore davantage avec les
réseaux sociaux c'est plus facile de
communiquer de ce côté là
donc là on essaie aussi pour genou au
québec mais un peu partout à travers le
monde de mieux comprendre qu'est ce qui
se passe c'est quoi ses couettes comment
on devient un peu compliqué ce contrat
parce que c'est sur quelque chose
d'arriver et hydrate combat rien ça
marche pas ça fait je sens pyrite fait
que cette voie vraiment top
qu'est-ce qu'est ce qui se passe parce
qu'il ya un accent très très très là
sont totalement convaincu mon propos
faire grand chose mais à un autre groupe
sont plus exposés que si je comprends
mal quoi parce que tu sur cette histoire
c'est finalement peut-être avec ces
groupes-là pas nécessairement le dire
qu'ils ont tort mais plutôt les bains
peut-être qu'on peut vous parler un peu
plus de la méthode encore une fois une
jeune scientifique comment ces faits
s'ils disputaient eux plus de genre de
chercheurs qui ont impliqué des groupes
d'arges semblables des jeunes des moins
jeunes est tout simple qui seront pas
jour ces chercheurs qui en parlent mais
aussi le commun des mortels qui
l'expliquent non si aux gens dans
société de l'importance justement tpiy
de la vulgarisation plus de la
communication pour moi c'est tellement
ça paraît tellement comme essentielle
parce que une population qu'une
littératie
scientifiques et techniques que des
bonnes bases solides justement vont être
moins enclins à croire toutes sortes de
choses qui voit passer sur leurs réseaux
sociaux vont être pitié c'est parce
qu'après ça la politique
si je pense que ça c'est vrai que chaque
décision politique est toujours 100%
basé sur le consensus scientifique la 2d
fois ci on a une majorité de la
population donne un exemple qui serait
climato sceptiques
ben après suspects auraient lieu de
paimpol choix de la date dans la
direction de de tabac qui votent donc le
plus ta population et éduquer
scientifiquement mais plus aussi la
politique la science peut travailler
main dans la main
c'est un très très bon point c'est ce
qu'on essaie de faire rome puisque avait
un petit peu avec la science
participative en iran puis le citoyen
que le citoyen et le chercheur se
rencontre plus souvent ni encore une
fois dans le temps de programmes qu'on a
sur les sciences participatives
oui le résultat mais pas vraiment ce qui
m'intéresse le résultat de l'expérience
ça marche tant mieux là mais c'est
plutôt encore une fois des deux connais
tu te connaître l'autre devoir acheter
un chercheur ou une chercheuse jugement
de fond dans l'épicerie comme tout le
monde mais bon il ya une formation
pointue dans un secteur mais on peut
leur parler ils sont ouverts à tous donc
pour ça que d'expliquer davantage à nos
concitoyens je pense est très important
et comme tu disais à l'homme en est
c'est eux qui va te presser le fait que
le lycée ne pouvoir élu parce que tant
que par exemple quand je
on donne des avis dans les poches quand
même comme le mien oui legault les élus
vont regarder les banques et sociales y
donnait probants des données
scientifiques mais à côté de ça il ya
aussi tout l'impact sur la société le
train fait qu'ils sont ils pensent à
sempy généralement la politique accru la
science est un élément mieux plus que ça
il s'en faut l'accepter et ce quand je
suis arrivé aux portes de son
laboratoire avec des jumeaux j'étais
très chanceux des équipes de jeunes ou
les chercheurs sont d'étudiants qui sont
partout à travers le monde me demande
vraiment fabuleux et l'auto tête est
habitué des clients une publication
scientifique tambours
sané 7 revient plus gens te dire non
c'est pas possible on saute se diraient
ils comprennent rien
on fait ça comme ça tu arrives dans le
monde politique ce doit rendre
totalement différent là et l'échelle de
temps pour la même chose qu'on creuse et
c'est aussi il ya des considérations
beaucoup plus large que la donne est
probant points
oui c'est important d'avoir ça mais ça
prend plus que ça et comme à blizzard
est pour moi je prends la décision avec
art en amont laboratoire et là bas moi
je donne des avis et ambitieux c'est le
gouvernement qui décide sentez-vous prix
commandeur feu deux fois je te
raconterai ce côté le scientifique ou
est ce qu'elle est la donnée probante et
la chose suprême versus le la politique
ou est ce que c'est pour toujours le cas
mais vous devez un genre de pont entre
ces deux cd chose je pense que je n'ai
pas d'ailleurs dans quoi je m'embarquais
je vais sans cesse ça m'intéressait pas
vraiment ce poste le point de départ le
cas pourquoi j'avais c'est karl et j'ai
été contacté le camp le ministre gignac
à ce moment là des sacrés pas payer les
gens qui m'appelaient puis chercheur de
taille leur dire non non non belle tête
des personnes vont peut-être intéressé
fait qu'ils sont revenus à plusieurs
reprises moi ça allait très bien mon
laboratoire libyennes recherchent des
biens beaucoup de plaisir à faire ça il
a finalement bon ou si ces banques que
je vais aller les voir allez-vous voir
byblos h entrée la dépression arrive le
jour au lendemain c'est une belle carte
d'affaires c'est un peu sexy c'est pas
de la tarte
qu'est ce que je fais qu'est ce qu'il
fait avec ça un boulet un scientifique
l'achat qu'une fois qu'ils l'ont tous
fait la tête avait un peu tout un peu
tout à construire ce qui peut que j'aime
beaucoup quand on commence quelque chose
j'ai toujours aimé ce plus que lorsque
tu le 2e ou 3e - mais tout ça c'est un
changement de façon de faire et c'est
d'accepter des valeurs auxquelles les
roses ont changé si je veux vraiment
prendre cette décision non pas juste à
l'emprise est toujours à me présenter à
donner au début du mois
6 juin à 10 h on avisera fête ses 2
mètres dans la tête aussi
mais ce qui est dingue qui fascine en
même temps parler un peu de certaines
thématiques parce qu'on est exposé des
choses nouvelles à chaque jour ouais
c'est tellement vaste ces chocs depuis
quelques mois on dit beaucoup pandémie
mais c'est tellement va dans tous les
secteurs
littérature les arts bien sûr en santé
les caribous tout sauf à ça c'est
vraiment intéressant
vous apprenez toujours des nations des
fois des fois il ya des frustrations
bientôt dans n'importe quel genre de
travail mais en même temps lorsqu'on est
on est près des communautés de
chercheurs
ici au québec puis à l'internacional
puis interagir avec avec les élus
je trouve ça toujours très très très
intéressant très stimulant et leur
parler un peu de science aussi une norme
démarrer des programmes de petit
déjeuner à l'assemblée nationale sur
cette intéressante j'ai même connu que
l'idée c'était des [ __ ] manet qui ont
du bagout on aimerait entendre parler
davantage de sciences la highway et puis
là c'était tous les partis le parti au
pouvoir
enfin dans sa partie de béral qui doit
pouvoir puis on dit on aimerait entendre
parler de science le dit ok on vous a
mené de chercheurs sur des sujets qui le
sujet est le premier sujet qui m'ont
proposé c'est ce qu'on appelle
christopher kas ninth et c'est la
méthode de modification du génome qui
est du prix nobel et de femmes ont un
prix nobel et d'une ferme dans cette
année le camp du monde soit on va tendre
par les crises par watt
c'est un peu particulier est vraiment ce
parce que db nous en termes de thérapie
génique
on commence à en entendre parler dans
notre comté des gens qui ont des
maladies incurables et oysho quelques
parents demain peut-être ça pourrait
m'aider moi qu'est ce qu'on pense sauf
éventuellement emilie projet de loi qui
m'ont aller là dessus avec son dauphin
est dotée de 4 5 ans qu'on a commencé et
c'est toujours très stimulant on a même
des chercheurs de chercheurs ils vont
parler pendant trois quatre minutes on
dit toujours le sport
20 minutes la spanish bonne présentation
dans un congrès scientifique l'a
vraiment du très haut niveau
hélas les députés posent des questions
j'essaie toujours de très bonnes
questions tout le très surprenant
et ça ça permet aussi de démystifier un
peu vrai
la science la recherche d est ce que
vous trouvez que les coupes du
gouvernement est somme toute bonne par
rapport aux données scientifiques
ici l'on doit dire aussi au québec on
est quand même assez assez chanceux je
parlais des fonds de recherche du québec
ça ça existe ici depuis une cinquantaine
d'années la des années 60 70
on reste encore aujourd'hui à peu près
la seule province au canada qui ont des
conseils subventionnaires au niveau de
la province et un haut niveau du
gouvernement fédéral
miss donc au québec depuis plusieurs
décennies indépendamment du parti au
pouvoir
il ya des investissements qui sont
relativement significatif en recherche
et innovation
donc soyons une tradition depuis très
longtemps cette ouverture l'autre et là
qu'on a vu depuis la pandémie et avec la
science qui est là tous les jours à côté
de premier ministre tout ça non classés
et on voit tous les jours
facal est à des chercheurs sont dans les
journaux aussi quotidiennement la
télévision et sont donc très présent
ce qui fait que des collègues aux
fonctionnaires ou des élus des petits
mini ce qu'eux aussi ont découvert
qu'elle veut scientifique en chef au
québec qui ont découvert qu'ils avaient
tant de chercheurs dans toutes sortes de
disciplines ce qui fait que nous depuis
le monde marche en m
on n'a jamais eu autant de demandes de
plusieurs ministères avec lesquels on
avait peu de liens qui se bat nous on a
des questions de recherche est ce que
vous pourriez nous aider là dedans donc
de ce côté là aussi ça ça ouvert
beaucoup en terme en termes de
gouvernement et l'importance de la
science et on ne travaillait beaucoup
avec notre ministère
d'autres milieux c'est aussi avec les
avec des finances et finalement le
ministère des finances a décidé
d'investir davantage en disant belle et
la science la recherche a beau faire
partie
la reprise économique autant de ce côté
là on est quand même assez bien
et assez bien positionné c'est ce qu'a
faut pas lâcher il ya toujours de
toujours faut démontrer ça peut être ça
pète ça peut être utile mais en termes
d'impact économique on le bruit
l'oublier c'est souvent aussi jeux sont
montréal les universités sont montréal
avec des étudiants avec les profs 200cc
des milliers et des milliers d'emplois
et autant d'emplois dans le domaine dans
les universités sur montréal canada
aérospatiale secteur très porteur en
terme d'économie web est ici si je suis
issu électorale
par exemple on était bien parti si elle
se dit que je peux fondée après ce ma
compagnie pitié après ce avoir jeté de
thomas tuchel ou ou peu importe le thé à
prayssas et l'innovation tcc ça si en
retour a sonné ensuite mois et se situe
à un très bon point de plus en plus là
dans mon temps car moi j'ai fait mais
c'est tous des yvelines et s'impose de
recherche table sur 120 universités
maintenant souvent les jeunes devront
arrêter un bout de temps ils vont
commencer il personnes qui prennent un
deux trois ans il fonde chose j'arrête
ils reviennent et on coud et le linéaire
est aussi beaucoup plus d'intérêt à
démarrer sa propre entreprise
et ça c'est assez fabuleux depuis même
depuis que j'en passe là depuis quelques
années pour les jeunes devaient 25 1 2
et en particulier des jeunes femmes
quittent plus ou moins dans ce secteur
d'après trân entrepreneuriat donc y en a
de plus en plus donc nous aussi on de
démarrer quelques petits programmes là
qu'on appelle entrepreneuriat créativité
nom de l'entrepreneuriat scientifique
d'aider ces jeunes là si plutôt que
d'aller faire un post doc werrity par
exemple c'est bien moi je m'intéressais
peut-être dès mardi mâcon pays
comment donner des outils à ces jeunes
là qu'ils puissent démarrer leurs
petites compagnies en espérant la voir
grandir dans le temps tant que ça je
pense ça fait partie aussi de notre
mandole c'est pas tout le monde qui veut
devenir un professeur d'université il
faudrait pas non plus et quelqu'un peut
créer sa compagnie crée des emplois
par la suite un cri et doute souvent
pour des jeunes qui craignent un combat
visant surtout dans le domaine là
d'intelligence artificielle
il va de soi sont millionnaires à 21 h
on a créé à l'écouté et à l'opposé si
quelqu'un et ça marche pas vêtu d'un t
c'est quelque chose ça marche pas de ce
fait faillite
ballottés pote doit pas être strati
zélande roeser d'être aussi bon depuis
on veut plus que moi avec un peu comme
en israël
tu apprends à chaque fois même ça marche
pas pu surveiller tu recommences une
deuxième fois puis une troisième fois
peut demander à bon marché c'est que ça
c'est quelque chose on a changé notre
monde très vite et un peu au québec
possible de dire on apprend toujours
même si des fois ça marche tellement
bien on va apprendre de nos erreurs
la prochaine fois savoir les mieux sinon
si on essaie de stimuler ce beaucoup je
trouve ça vraiment perturbant de penser
que c'est dans les dernières années que
les les différents les différents pans
du gouvernement se tourne vers la
science et pour prendre des décisions
plus éclairées
alors que il sent que ça réduirait
dessus depuis tellement longtemps alors
que toutes les décisions au final sont
basés sur de la recherche le type
décision qu'on devrait prendre devraient
pas être basée sur ce puits juste de
vous entendre dire que dans deux plus
deux dernières années la les ministres
commencent à se tourner les ministres
commencent à se tourner vers la science
ainsi s'il y en avait qui avait déjà à
l'inter nous aussi il y avait des
vêtements peut-être y avait plus de
recherches à l'intérieur même des
ministères donc il sort dans les années
80 90 et des problèmes économiques et
tous ceux dont plusieurs ministères que
ce soit au gouvernement fédéral ou
provincial dans plusieurs provinces
finalement on décide de délester des
bons on n'a peut-être pas besoin de soan
interne et on l'a vu par exemple
en tout du transport mais ça le
transport ou un moniteur plus de
compétences beaucoup à l interne pour
analyser la science qui se fait au jour
le jour pénaliser des résultats donc
sans et là on est à reconstruire je
pense que la pandémie l'eau si ça nous
au tribal où on doit être capable
d'avoir ce genre de connaissances la
halle interne dans plusieurs des dix
structures que l'on offre soit des
mystères des organismes que tu sois
c'est vrai je dirais que c'est vrai
globalement dans en europe en amérique
du nord là on ne dit mot on n'a plus
besoin de nous être capable de produire
de l'acsel ça peut le faire
les molécules médicaments besoin de
faire cette capacité manufacturière dont
les muguets des micropuces est fait tout
est devenu très centralisé certains
endroits du monde en pensant qu'on va
sauver des sous de ce côté là ça va te
mange un mélange rencontre où on devient
très dépendant depuis est un produit des
masques à kiev et je pense que ça soit
aussi ça va d'une leçon de cette
pandémie là ça serait compte des
capacités de production davantage de
toute la chaîne de l'innovation la
recherche très fondamentale à la
commercialisation est aussi que la
science pour prendre des décisions
on devrait peut-être y pense un peu plus
long je pense que dans certains secteurs
étaient plus présents nous un public
d'un secteur de la santé ainsi on pense
par exemple pour des années 60-70 c'est
quelqu'un qui faisait une crise
cardiaque et amour et beaucoup et aïssa
prenait 6 mois avant de retourner
travailler et maintenant et freine
qu'ils gardent ya 48 heures est pris ce
terrain de golf
ils sont cinq roues d'acier ans accros
de la recherche excédé il ya des
secteurs où ce thème beaucoup plus
présent que d'autres mais maintenant je
pense à temps généralisé que que la
chose scientifique important pour tout
le monde puis je me suis que leurs
clauses et années j'avais entendu que
justement c'était à l'époque du
gouvernement fédéral conservateur qu'il
y avait une espèce de surtout une seule
question du screamo les scientifiques tp
récemment libre de communiquer les
résultats de leurs recherches
juste comme cela devait passer par le
gouvernement de contrôler un peu de la
communication scientifique s qui s'est
encore le couple non mais c'est vrai que
des allégeances politiques là des fois
qui fait que sur ce gouvernement là il y
avait ça y avait paul poce un peu
d'équivalents siens de fait qu'un chef
il l'enfermé donc pas besoin de ça ne
peuvent être pendus d'ici n'ont pas
besoin de ça
les cas aussi le président termine je
suis trompé terminé on peut voir un tout
les plusieurs des organisations
côté recherche et aussi de côté
environnement il ya plus de financements
énormément l'environnement tous on est
plus dans son ex a été le seul à
remettre sur pieds par 12 pays qui ont
fait ce genre de choix là aussi
envisager mon temps je suis chez moi
patron maintenant besoin de demander de
vieilles personnes de cet âge des sites
a commandé cette rebondi d'enfer c'est
aussi l'année mais puisque pour ça qu'on
est quand même chanceux globalement ici
au québec depuis j'ai des cinquantaine
d'années alors vraiment de dire d'un
parti ou l'autre la science quand même
importante des fois on est plus un peu
plus de financement du fonds un peu
moins mais globalement c'est s était
soutenue depuis plusieurs décennies ce
qui trait est très positif dans la
communauté scientifique
si on vient au changement climatique un
petit peu dans la communauté
scientifique semble avoir rêve de deux
visions du truc
il ya des gens qui sont en fait je peux
mettons en levant la prémisse dans la
communauté scientifique c'est que j'ai
l'impression qu'il ya deux visions par
rapport aux changements climatiques pour
ceux qui croient beaucoup en la science
comme étant sont optimistes par rapport
à la science puis les caisses que la
science pourrait amener pour se sortir
de ce pétrin le et à d'autres qui en
suivant les données scientifiques sont
extrêmement pessimiste par rapport à la
trajectoire des changements climatiques
ou est ce que quelqu'un comme vous se
place dans tout ça en voyant les
nouvelles avancées en voyant les
statistiques de réchauffement qui qui
parle pour elle ment et moi se
constituent dans cette question là parce
que c'est un enjeu qui sont en fait pour
moi personnellement puis trop mollement
pour les gens fument des clopes qui
somme toute assez existentielle et y non
moi je suis très optimiste de nature
toujours là je pense que que la science
va aider à s'en sortir la recherche pour
aider là où on doit ici qu'on essaie de
faire un petit peu maintenant aussi là
c'est de dire la science pure et dure
qui est absolument essentiel dans ce
secteur là bas c'est pas suffisant de se
faire dire par le giec que deux degrés
s'est trop de bons vins goût 1.5 on
l'entend l'entente longtemps ce que je
connais c'est de faire un peu plus
maintenant ces deux baisses de traduire
son terme un peu plus concret ce que
j'écoute les pandémies c'est très
concret d'entre eux peut ici aussi là
qu'est ce que ça peut vouloir dire pour
moi parce qu'en fait un grand discours
aux nations unies
ouais c'est beau puis on se comprend
qu'ils se créent une certaine dynamique
certaine anxiété au niveau du
gouvernement fédéral la même chose et
même au niveau des grandes cuvées danse
pour vraiment arriver là dans mondial
dans ma ville dans mon quartier ce que
ça peut vouloir dire pour moi cette
affaire mais et c'est ce qu'on essaie de
faire de plus en plus je pense que les
jeunes avec les disques on a vu que
manifestation cours des années là c'est
que j'espère que l'eau avec on veut
apprendre la pandémie il se dit comment
on pense à beaucoup plus concret pour
moi pour ma famille pour l'eff les
générations futures
et là de mettre davantage de pression
encore sous les gouvernements parce que
c'est ce que c'est moins aigu que dans
la pandémie n'autorise plus de lier
l'octave de lire j'en fais tu dans votre
médecin de mai et on peut plus fait le
faut vraiment trouver des façons de
faire
qui vont amener le politique à prendre
des décisions à plus longtemps et que ça
change pas nécessairement parce
qu'aujourd'hui c'est monsieur trempe de
mais c'est monsieur barry donne cela
soit beaucoup plus long terme et sans
que ça devienne plus concret qu'une
signature à paris comme la cob index
c'est de trouver des façons de rendre ce
très concret et moi l'âge qu'on
peut-être trop mais quand oui sur les
chercheurs encore plus sur nos
concitoyens de travailler ensemble dans
des sciences citoyennes des sciences
participatives et comment on peut
travailler ensemble pour diminuer
peut-être l'impact sur notre
environnement de ce que je fais on a
pris un peu de recul
la pandémie ben c'était bon partout dans
le monde pro mode - après en même temps
il y en a qui y étaient il ya des
gentils mais moi je prends pas le but
maintenant je prends pas pas le métro je
m en auto n'ont taghit vieux puits plus
documenté la classe de ramener les gens
au sic et qu'ils aient confiance vers ok
oui c'est parfait d'être capable de
reprendre à prendre des transports en
commun puis j'irai plus m'éloigne
répètent pas nécessairement un trop trop
trop de mon lieu de travail
mais certains que la pandémie de bons
côtés ils n'auraient côté de ce côté là
aussi je pense qu'il faut travailler
avec nos concitoyens
il est amené les décideurs politiques à
prendre davantage là de dire bah c'est
une question de ça va changer où il a
pendu ou changer des choses méchantes
votre métier mon premier change encore
plus donc faut vraiment trouver une
façon de ralentir sur tout ça l'économie
circulaire aussi en terme de façon de
faire pour mambo nourris des deux côtés
c'est vraiment que tout ce faire le
travail
le ticket si c'est si les scientifiques
conscientisent le public le public après
sa élit des politiciens qui représente
csd le pipi après ce cp le ciel vont
mettre des lois pour seuls les citoyens
que ce qui vous toujours d'avoir une
gamme qui vont jamais vouloir un parking
et à qui on vous jamais
puis après celui de laval une ovation
pitt il justement la science pure et the
most eu l'impression comme vous disiez
plutôt que différents différentes
sphères travailler ensemble pour que
justement développer des technologies
concrètes noted était comme un con je
sais pour capturer le co2 dans
l'atmosphère comme acoustique cas
quelles machines ont créé le tri pour
eux
comment on refroidit la puis en même
temps mais on l'a avec télétravail
énormément temps joseph qui était très
bon côté de ça aussi mais on utilise de
plus en plus d'internet de plus en plus
de 400 jeunes et beaucoup de chaleur
aussi
chaque lot de ce côté les yeux vous
trouver de nouvelles façons de faire
mais les dans les nouvelles façons de
faire
probablement commence à parler
d'ordinateurs quantiques donc c'est
prenant la prochaine prochaine étape et
les arbres m'a demandé beaucoup moins
d'énergie augmente a énormément les
capacités d'analysé me demander beaucoup
moins dix offres à bas quand croisic
partir tout de la physique cointrin loin
mais c'est aussi le concert des concepts
de physique quantique d'un chercheur
université de montréal qui a découvert
jeudi gilles g bras ça dans les années
soixante dix
et s'ils avaient tous deux nient ou dans
cette épure bien pour moi qui rédige un
prix nobel ou si il y ait beaucoup de
politiques pour les primes à bernon
comme comme dans n'importe quel monde je
pense qu'on est dans quel prix et les
chercheurs oui on va être pur et dur
mais de ce côté là aussi c'est un cd
réseau un is it a pas eu tel tel type de
prix avant il faut bâtir une carrière de
ce côté là j'ai eu des banques quand
même des bons prix mais pas eu encore
celui-là mais l'oeil des grosses
entendre en physique quantique et du
côté ordinateur quantique qui se
développe à chexbres ici au québec c'est
vraiment cher maintenant qui est le
centre de tout ça il ya des jeunes le
boxon fabuleux un peu comme on a ici à
montréal avec le milan au choix bendjo
d'intelligence artificielle au choix ya
quinze monts de ces constats faire
joujou avec des des chiffres l'effet des
mathématiques appliquées
ça change erm en physique wathier qu'on
est peut-être l'heure un peu aussi là et
puis dire ça va aller de plus en plus
vers l'ordinateur quoi entièrement ça
fonctionne leur ordinateur finalement
c'est la capacité d' analyse qui est qui
énorme qui magnifie des milliers de fois
donc l'ordinateur un peu ordinaire c'est
zéro et la hollande tandis que le croate
qui analysent 0 et en même temps de donc
l'analogique lac semble être cher boucle
chercheurs qui là dedans utilise très
souvent une très très belle bibliothèque
européenne langue est très très très
fine select architecture des milliers et
des milliers de vaud le débat là avec ce
qu'on a présentement le numérique qu'on
a présentement je dis bien trouver moi
je mène ce plumes dans un des bouquets
des milliers de bouquins qu'il a trouvé
moi où est le plus donc là présentement
l'ordinateur va prendre le premier vol
plus vite que moi elle me prend le
premier volume qu'il peut leur apprendre
d'eux tandis que le coin qui comprend
tous les volumes en même temps on
analyse tout tout tout en même temps
fixé il est presque un premier
ordinateur aquatique qui était annoncée
la part des grandes compagnies
américaines par google l'an dernier et
où finalement il faisait on est capable
de faire du calcul qui aurait pris des
années et des années en versant quelques
minutes avec le coin tic dantesque avec
l'ordinateur
sophie ski présentement ça prend des
années sa part faire accélérer tout dans
toute l'histoire
ça va ça va save est énorme aussi en
terme en terme d' analyse de capacités
d'analysé de grandes bases de données à
de près d'avoir des accords est un peu
de meilleure qualité un peu plus
prédictif encore je pense qu'il va
maintenant lui prédit qu ils vont savoir
qu'est ce que tu veux avant tout c'est
shia déjà ça
je pense ça va être des grandes études
épidémiologiques des études de
changement climatique par exemple les
capacités d'ordinateurs sont presque pas
longtemps lorsque tu arrives en sciences
humaines des grandes années de sciences
humaines maintenance altran énormément
de capaci d'ordinateurs donc avec le
coin c'est que ça va aider beaucoup de
ce côté là non plus on peut imaginer ce
que ça va être accessible qu'un
probablement je dirais pas vraiment
quinzaine d'années malgré déjà des
prototypes l'appui ibm et des grandes
pompes et que je pense que ça va être
plus rapidement que ça mais avant que
peut-être nous on voit là au jour le
jour peut-être je me dirai peut-être une
quinzaine d'années encore une fois ça va
changer complètement de façon
complètement c'est fou vous le monde
mettant le monde du futur par
l'innovation vous vous le voyez d'un de
bonne augure d'un bon oeil
oui la direction quand qu'on consent vos
pratiques la science parce que tu es en
même temps quelqu'un pourrait argumenter
que la science est aussi ce qui nous a
menés dans un peu dans le pétrin qu'on
est présentement dans terme mais qu
écologique pitso de la crise
industrielle
mais vous pensez que c'est aussi ce qui
va nous ouvrir à je pense que oui je
pense que c est vraiment un bidet
pandémie malheureusement on ne se soit
la dernière qu'on les experts il se
voyait pas si agressif que ça c'est
panique à on a besoin de joindre
sciences de ce côté là où on doit
peut-être la pandémie nous à travailler
même c'est à dire bayonne aspects de de
bien commun la table et un aspect de
société fait défaut par faut pas dire
qu'il y en a et sahil du travail à faire
parce que l'économie nous emmener un
point de vue yeux des gens excessivement
que si maxime en arich les autres sont
encore plus beau temps il faut avoir en
termes de répartition de recherche de
biens communs je pense que la science
doit aider lyon 2 c pour second doit
mettre la science ne peut plus pur et
dur mais avec l'assistance des sciences
humaines des sciences
pour être pour tenir contre bafa que
c'est pas juste l'aspect de 10 rebonds
viennent découvrir on vient de points
développé une nouvelle technologie qui
va nous permettre d'aller encore cinq
fois plus vite
ouais mais deuxième est ce que c'est
acceptable socialement 7 cette nouvelle
technologie donc de bâtir sa avec des
expériences sociales et sciences
humaines et pour moi avec le concitoyen
donc avoir vraiment de la co création de
programmation scientifique pour
s'assurer qu'on l'espère sont en arrière
tous sont une des inquiétudes qu'on
avait on a toujours ce que certains
points avec l'intelligence artificielle
c'est que dire si on n'a pas de
littératie numérique même année ça va
être aussi bien que pour savoir lire
très important de ne pas perdre de vue
non visé la difficulté pile dedans j'ai
l'impression avec les nouvelles
technologies c'est que ça ça arrive
tellement rapidement qu'on ne presque
pas le temps de s'adapter
l'action est déjà rendu ailleurs je te
matam et on l'a on pense à tes aux
applications nouvelles
je pensais du bar airbnb pseudo même pas
le temps mais des règles là dessus qu'on
est déjà rendu l'âme et les auraient
déjà rendu ailleurs évolue tellement
rapidement que j'ai l'impression que
j'étais mettons t-il exemple le monde en
50 ans ont gelé mais tant qu'on peut à
peine l'imaginer comment ça va être
différent tandis que entre autres la
1200 plants 1250 pas grave c'est assez
ça va de plus à savon plus en plus
rapidement
puis c'est ce qui justement
l'intelligence artificielle c'est
quelque chose que j'ai l'impression peut
tellement basculer d'un côté ou de
l'autre le tir on a tous envie d'être
une science fiction le dit stop et qu
est-ce qu il l a senti ciel détruire
mais non on est capable il m'a dit mais
justifie marking le dit lui-même qui a
indiqué cindy l'une des six tonnes et
ses craintes pour pour l'aei pour
l'avenir mais moi je vois plus ce que je
crains le plus c'est de laisser des gens
en arrière ceux qui auraient manqué pas
de littératie numérique
ça devrait commencer le plus tôt
possible commencer ou à l'école primaire
where it sopi est ce que les jeunes
l'utilisent beaucoup là mais savoir un
petit peu plus quitte en arrière de tout
ça un peu comment ça marche
qu'est ce qui apparaît sur notre
téléphone pourquoi pourquoi tel conflit
paraît tout d'un coup ça vient d'où ce
soir là d'abord été tout seul je pense
aussi important pour laisser personne en
arrière ça va te fait de faire critiques
ont très très très important
l'aspect plus fantastique la pandémie
thé avec les meetings de famille menacée
on a vu qu'il y avait des jeux un gap
énorme entre les générations est souvent
les grands parents qui pendant les
meetings zoom ils se sentent un petit
peu décalé par rapport aux plus jeunes
parce que le caecum inquiet mais je sais
pas comment ça fonctionne comment je
fais pour parler pour que je peux gabat
de parler ça parle pas de ceux déjà le
train écoles fait que je peux comprendre
effectivement que ça peut être un danger
laisser des gens derrière cannes c'est
même moi des fois le don des jeunes
l'ont mérité j'ai 30 ans pis et des fois
je suis poli je dis souvent que des gens
comme jean disant qu'ils sont venus avec
quelques cheap de plus que moi que c'est
déjà organisé de ce côté là mais c'est
certainement même temps froid si de
comprendre un peu ce qui en arrière de
tout cela et c'est vrai qu'on doit pas
laisser personne en arrière et là aussi
prêt de changer les façons de faire de
ce club c'est peut-être les petits
enfants peuvent accéder aux grands
parents comment commencer mois il
souffre d'un cancer des enfants à toi
quand ça vient des petits enfants et
leurs mamans utilise un pays cela grâce
aux billets font souvent c'est plus
facile d'acceptation des deux côtés il
permet de créer des liens de ce côté-là
régénération et rationnelle j'imaginais
aussi les élèves
de deux sociétés naissance qui est y
avoir accès à la technologie des
téléphones intelligents voir toute
l'information du monde dans ma poche
pratiquement ça me donne un avantage
versus quelqu'un ou une ch'ti ou un
groupe qui aurait moins axé ses
technologies le kin vous pourrez
peut-être plus le se développer puis
tous se économiquement avec ses
avantages le versus un autre faux key t
météorologiques on le vit dans
l'histoire qu'un que technologie était
dit non mais aussi technologiques et
éthique et tapez donc donc l'impression
faux faux faux absolument réfléchir en
temps réel les nouvelles innovations qui
sortent parce que sinon si un éthicien
philosophes ou un cdd qui se penche sur
la question ça peut devenir très
dangereux
l'intelligence et et à la déclaration de
morales qui était co construite nos
joies bendjoudi beaucoup là-dedans des
chercheurs de new york mariano fondre
sur eux pour dire ok qu'est ce qui est
acceptable ou des sociétés éthiquement
qu'est ce qui l'est moins c'est de bâtir
la déclaration de morales qui vivent en
place a continué à évoluer pour dire ben
alors qu'est ce que notre société est
prêt à accepter ce lieu ce tableau le
plot de problèmes que je mentionnais
aussi et comme par exemple québec
ces grands de québec mois mais le fait
qu'ils aient des gens qui aient pas
accès à internet haute vitesse
même yves balet sont défavorisés c'est
sûr il en arrive qu on envoie tout le
monde en télétravail ou indication
distance et des régions du québec
ou ils n'ont pas nécessairement accès ça
et globalement on est quand même
privilégie sans voix dans certaines
régions du monde il y en a - encore
inconnue ces gens là vont peut-être
rester encore plus en arrière je pense
qu'une responsabilité des pays riches
comme nous de dire bâillon faut essayer
d'aider davantage encore ces régions du
monde à
cet été un des côtés qui en théorie
positive mais à date est encore un petit
peu négatif par rapport au vaccin et on
veut un groupe international avec
l'organisation mondiale de santé et
l'accès pour tout le monde mais les
états unis en acheter un certain montant
les canadiens d'acheter ' démontable
allemagne plaque la france et
l'angleterre
enfin qu'on protège nos citoyens pour
peut comprendre écouter politique mais
mais il faut aussi s'assurer que ces
vaccins la ville disponible à tout le
monde pas juste pas juste pour les pays
riches là et ça c'est ça reste encore un
défi là et on n'est pas rendu là et
d'après plusieurs chercheurs en option
on est tous vaccinés demain matin mais
qui est plusieurs régions du monde
qu'ils sont bons un peu plus avancés
n'ont aucun demande comment tu
recommences à voyager partout travers
travers le monde je pense ce genre dé
quitter l'as travail très importante
dans plusieurs secteurs et d'amener la
des philosophes des héritiers comme tu
disais des expériences association
humaine très très important de se mettre
davantage en avant scène des
collaborateurs avec des gens unique des
gens en santé prévention de santé parce
que ses seuls at-il la plus grande
utopie qu'on peut espérer pour la
planète c'est que tout le monde allait
les mêmes privilèges puis tout le monde
et les accès aux mêmes même technologie
ne serait là qu'on aurait vraiment on
serait vraiment arriver à un monde qui
bombent trio démons mais la passion
fatalement mais c'est vrai que tout
était tellement accéléré
oui mais certainement aujourd'hui j'ai
des rapports commencé à recevoir de
différents pays il faut apprendre de ce
qui s'est passé depuis plusieurs mois
pandémie là se remette en question petit
peu remettre de façon de faire je peux
je suis toujours optimiste mais jacques
une anxiété qu'on va voir la tendance à
retourner dans les eaux nous nous
défendons vieilles pantoufles fois que
ça redevienne on en a souffert pendant
quelques mois la l'on peut relaxer qu'on
devrait réaliser pin avec quelques
jeunes écrire c'est aussi récemment où
il convient c'est pas nécessairement
sympathique de les confinements écrit
mme en bout de ligne c'est possible
non c'est savoir la première guerre
mondiale guerre
je sais pas se voir des bombes des temps
de la tête 2-1 dénoncer ça mais brille
pas la pire année de l'histoire du même
pays et des peuples
c'est sûr on est quand même privilégié
par rapport à plusieurs d'entre nous
quand même un thème oui hanoi
il ya des gens qui ont souffert plus que
plus que moi globalement quand même pas
si mal par rapport à des grandes guerres
moules à tout le monde pendant 10 étapes
sur plusieurs plusieurs années les deux
du tube de 10 de grands garçons sur
plusieurs années les épidémies au moyen
âge aussi le petit quand ce n'est pas de
vaccin qui s'en viennent
non ça c'est pas c'est pas un pour cent
de la population qui en sur elle c'est
tout le monde qui par leurs jambes là
pour ça pour continuer à investir du
goûter séance côté recherche pour être
capable de continuer à avancer protéger
côté des pandémies il faut être mieux
préparer la prochaine fois pour gueule
tout le monde sauf moi ça fait bien plus
d'optimisme cinq ans qu'on a mis quand
on a le nez collé dessus des des
pessimistes le doc de regarder ce qui se
passe aux etats unis je serai saman de
regarder ce qui se passe avec l'équipe
mode a regardé tous habités
on est en train de vivre la fin du monde
pour vivre mais restera ça va aller
aussi le nom je prélève un bouquet d'une
prix nobel de littérature une paladin
attendre et ipad je trouverais période
de 16e 17e et tout ça dans la comédie
puis la comète ça fait du monde
quand des gens l'appareil cc dieu dieu
nous envoie ce message là la fin du
monde arrive partout mais au moins
maintenant on sait pourquoi pas de
matelas commettez pas envoyé par dieu
que vous détruire de ce côté-là non ce
côté là c'est ce qu'ont puis des fois je
dis aux gens dans on peut sauter une
journée ou deux sans lire les quotidiens
sam hamad sinon est accroché belle
aujourd'hui c'est 1933 qu'aux neuf
bières ses buts 200 demandes des cantons
note romain serman trop d'informations
mais quand on est pris beaucoup
là-dedans
si on a des tempéraments un peu anxieux
ça fait juste
on en parle et j'ai exactement le saut
avec ce nul piège thomas pedretti et
l'ajustement ali vraiment plus justement
les nouvelles bd oui je n'ai pas le
savoir de toute façon était allé this
parce que je veux pas les nouvelles vox
et sur les nouvelles qui sont négatives
parce que c'est ce qui retient toute
l'attention puisque qu'on juge qui
équipe plus pertinent à partager mais si
ça ça crée une espèce de d'anxiété
généralisée le cac institut qui consomme
c'est au jour le jour
puis conseiller ça fait du bien on n'a
pas de recul se raconte aussi connu une
bonne chance de vivre dans la société
dans l'air convient présente loi et
comment
sonia de la même chose encore récemment
d'entendre le nom du bit aller promener
son chien la legal cac 40 avenue marie
venait me voir le limiter à quand un
tour d'horloge belge dany boon est moche
et ok qu'est ce que c'est basé ses coûts
quelle idée qu'elle était tenue à
l'épreuve des tons chier la fois calé
promène avant 8 heures mais je pense que
je ça d'avoir des dépôts jusqu'à un
certain point
parce que sinon on reste accroché un
nouvel continuellement continuellement
ça devient ça devient difficile pour moi
pour plusieurs personnes
je pense que pour essayer de s'en sortir
un petit moscou taylor est certain pour
les jeunes puis on voit avec
l'université distance le collège à
distance et moi c'est pas simple c'est
plus les niveaux d'anxiété augmenter ma
même temps ce pour trois plaies non plus
d'être non pas par jour buts et fait
oublier ses frais quelques uns des gens
te disent oh tu dois être mal bon bah
c'est vrai le pousse bien que des fois
ça va remettre ça dans un contexte qui
est ce qu est ce qui va te passer en
neurosciences reste magique ça reste un
attachement émotif pour vous c'est ce
domaine là puisque vous restez à l'affût
vraiment de la neuroscience vacances les
recherches en neurosciences
c'est plus difficile parce que tellement
de demandes sur le temps ça que j'aime
et j'ai eu quelques revues scientifiques
que je lis régulièrement là mais c'est
prenez simplement ciblé neurosciences je
dirais que c'est ma famille y
scientifique qui maillent de ce côté là
bas mes anciens étudiants qui sont
partout à travers le monde comme je
disais et j'ai encore beaucoup de bien
avec la majorité d'entre eux
ce soir avec un banc d'éminents
professeurs mais avant ce voyage est
souvent avec les premiers ministres des
mines et cela pour une mission au japon
puis leur disais toujours bas ce soir je
n'ai pas super avec vous parce que
toujours des des réunions de mission ce
soir je l'espère une mise en scène
étudiée avec la manière y en a partout
été très gentil avec eux ça me permet de
garder des liens par rapport à ce qui se
passe par exemple sentimentale mort
parce que j'en très sexy flag dans
différentes universités à travers à
travers le monde parce que pour moi si
ce dont je suis le plus fier de ma
carrière l'os et c'est ma famille
scientifique c'est vraiment avec eux que
j'ai eu énormément paisible trévières
aussi ce qu'est russe à faire nous
c'était sur la maladie d'alzheimer votre
si je sais les as tous les champs de la
faune travail d'écouté suicide
dépression schizophrénie air douleur
c'est assez j'étais un peu à un peu
différent peut-être de certains autres
chercheurs loua j'avais des bonnes
subventions de recherche puissent
travailler dans les domaines assez
différent de l'autre quand on faisait
des des réunions de laboratoire des
réunions d'équipé dans mon laboratoire
bay avait un groupe qui traverse la zone
mal au travail à sa dépression l'autre
arrière sur la douleur et mon plaisir
c'était des ébats écoute danse qui dit
la beauté et des toits dans mon projet
de te connecter les gens aussi de
connecter les gens j'aime et je mets ce
beaucoup m
ces gens là pour dire ben tu peux
toujours apprendre quelque chose de
différent donne puisque qui pourrait
t'aider toi dans ton projet sachant j'ai
vu énormément de plaisir à faire à faire
mais ce que quand la balle plus
spécifiquement de ces maladies comme
l'alzheimer escure est ce que à ce jour
on connaît par exemple à cause de cette
maladie
l'aco jusqu'à un certain point des co je
dirais plus que qu'une cause ya une
protéine qui est augmenté beaucoup dans
le cerveau des personnes naxos des
amendes pour dino n'est pas le produit
amyloïdes quitte à augmenter beaucoup et
notre ange qu'on appelle un euro
filaments qui relient des dix régions du
cerveau se sont portés à n'dotré
l'internet protéine tau ou est hyper
phosphorer les dents mais beaucoup de
phosphore sur scène fédérale
sur ces 2
à coeur assez assez fort de la mer les
idm
en plus de ça on perd certains types de
cellules qui contiennent des oeufs au
transmetteur le lez et une colline et
sens a été identifiée milieu des années
soixante dix la perte on a cité le
collège et là il ya beaucoup de travaux
dans ce domaine là pendant plusieurs
années par la suite lorsqu'on a commencé
à caractériser la protéine bêta amyloïde
les filaments tôt je pense qu'on peut
malheureusement les chercheurs du privé
et du public
on sent devenu je dirais presque des
croyants naudy des religieux grasset moi
je crois l'hypothèse amyloïdes les
autres non moi je crois la protéine tau
le res non mais finalement ça faisait d
un peu des clochers des écoles et on
allait déjà les dunes plusieurs congrès
sur la main les alzheimer à peu partout
dans le monde le dit et elie la gagne de
mire - t'as bien en rouge blanc manteau
blanc bleu joue et on nous appelait les
allées la protéine tau appelé les
touristes
il habille le raid les bâtisses les gens
ils croyaient tellement il ya un autre
notre protégé de l'apolipoprotéine le
popiste les hypothèses en fait des
hypothèses mais les gens mais les pas du
tout moi j'étais un insecte je croyais
ariel de sauvetage et mélangez tout
rejeter mais jeter à bout du congrès
hier aujourd'hui quand tout le monde est
parti veelers pb
ça se peut pas que ça vient qu
énormément d'énergie sur mis sur une
façon de moduler la mi-avril des
milliards de dollars investis rien de
concret ces sociétés des 50 décevant
mais ça ne manque que le cerveau quand
même assez fascinant coeur n'a pas
réussi à briser ou à bien connaître ce
temps cet organe n'a encore là c'est
encore très complètement une maladie
comme la mort malheureusement on n'a pas
vraiment traitement efficace après des
années d à 10 heures
maladies dégénératives comme celle là
mon pari neurochirurgie un pays où il
opère pour le parkinson dont
l'implantation d'une puce pour
stabiliser le parkinson un certain stade
est ce que cette avenue là
éventuellement serait une pour d'autres
types de maladies dégénératives comme
alzheimer ou c'est pour l'alzheimer
d'azheimer le bon type qu'attendent
parkinson vraiment qu'on s'y penche
comme ça non mais et si plus entre ses
six centrales izri une endroits précise
dans le surf est assez précis lorsque la
malaisie de s'avancer de ses plus larges
mais sinon c'est vraiment une rixe et à
son endroit qu'on est capables nous deux
régions seraient banques sont beaucoup
plus affectés
et là on peut aller là dedans avec des
pleins d'autres stratégies housse avec
des cellules souches et tout ça la
malice désamour c'est plus diffus donc
c'est un peu plus compliqué parce que
c'est il ya plusieurs régions du cortex
et d'époque amples des régions de serbie
qui dans mémoires qui sont affectés
effectuer une maladie qui progresse mais
quand le parking sont aussi me qui
progresse lentement
donc lorsque vraiment on se rencontre
oui c'est probablement ça départ tout
est rendue tard avec suzy essayé
beaucoup beaucoup d'études essayer de
trouver des marqueurs un foutoir où est
précoce de la maladie à date on nous les
seuls qu'on aurait eu si vraiment à voir
c'est vraiment la serre liées à la mise
aux ide le sait lorsque quelqu'un
développe l'alzheimer dans la
quarantaine ou même un peu en voyou
quelques cas ventes ou des buts
cinquantaine l'os parce que c'est très
génétique a eu des mutations dans la
mélodie et l'osm le traître est
hautement rapidement mais généralement
d'une maladie d' évolution très lente et
qui ou leur quantique en vraiment s'en
rend compte il ya pas beaucoup de
approche thérapeutique à tout - à dakhla
qui fonctionne puisque ce lait est ce
que c'est les jeunes s'en rendre compte
en premier ou leur entourage c'est
plutôt l'entourage provoque une certaine
frustration de la personne quand on se
rencontre on mendie peut qu'y pas
correct mais souvent plus l'entourage
qui dit oulala
il un problème très important taka date
pour essayer de professeur d'université
ça nous rend pas il me à tout ça mais
quand même un des facteurs qui ont
comprend plus ou moins bien grand mais
qui peut protéger contre les hammers et
l'éducation et on pense que c'est
peut-être parce qu'avec l'éducation
indus tu apprends petite aide au club tu
peux pas ouvrir la porte de cette façon
ou l'autre face et de l'ouvrir d'une
autre façon que tu développes une
certaine redondance en cerveau qui donne
plus de façon de manipuler tempère refus
un circuit battu vous travaillez avec
l'autre avec son éducation
ça sent bien protégé compte contre la
maladie d'azheimer des profs
d'université là aussi les l'éducation
dans le temps c'est ce qu'on connaît
l'avons fait des études c'est une puis
avancez vers 15 heures à l'avancé
il faut sans taj moins élevé des gens
qui ont fait des études avancées qui ont
développé un mois fabrique lorsqu'on est
des dimensions des blocs - d'alzheimer
est aussi se garder actif en
vieillissant un gars de garder son
cerveau actif et aussi physiquement
l'éducation la l'entraînement physique
sont aussi le premier facteur de
croissance que ça libère qui monte au
cerveau ça permet de protéger cerveau
contre ou de dégénérescence l'autre ses
activités cérébrales comme à saper des
échecs ou se mettre les mots croisés
mais par contre on dit souvent aussi un
carrefour on vient on stresse site à 61
15 78 des ter ces chèques toujours
détesté ça alors faut pas que je
commence à ce moment là ça va te stresse
et plus tôt et pire éclate toi vendée
effect plus négatifs du stress mais
dexia quelque chose que tu aimes ça
essayer de garder cette activité là et
finalement prom en plus des résultats de
scandinavie la socialisation aussi de ne
pas s'isoler vraiment de continuer
associait désocialisés souvent avec la
socialisation des activités activité
physique activité cérébrale donc
ça sent ça semble protéger encore une
fois il ya des gens qui vont faire ça
pour leur appareil là mais parce qu'on
mais on ne peut pas encore vraiment d'
approche thérapeutique de prenez sempy
ça peut diminuer de beaucoup le
développement de la maladie on ne peut
pas comme le diabète tout comme les
maladies cardiaques ou là on a vraiment
des traitements très efficaces
est ce que c'est quelque chose qui est
envisageable qui éventuellement ça
arrive je pense je pense que oui est
probable il promet qu'il va falloir
aussi avoir des meilleures façons de
reconnaître différents types d'alzheimer
longue mais peut-être un peu tous une
mamie japon lé même après tant d'années
de recherches et on est peut-être un peu
comme le cancer ou un peu comme les
maladies cardiaques ou quelqu'un qui
souffrait d'hypertension par exemple au
début des années 60
bella aux pressions du père tension mais
depuis avec la faucheuse qui a été fait
bon c'est des fois ça dépend des reins
des fois ça demande des vaisseaux
sanguins des france abrite dépend de ton
coeur des fois ça dépend de ton cerveau
quand on peut cibler le traitement c'est
à toi c'est les verts sont également
dotés d'un type de médicament le cancer
un peu la même chose il ya plusieurs
formes de cancer dans certains cols
cancer du sein de plusieurs formes de
cancer vous sert aussi certains on peut
les tétées assez bien avec une certaine
thérapie parce qu'ils ont les
modifications génétiques qui sont
associés à ceux d'autres savent même pas
pu me robots sont eux réussi à faire ça
dans ces secteurs là encore difficile
avec avec la démence je ne suis pas un
bon mélange souvent avec d'autres types
de demandes qu'on met souvent sous
chapeau d'alzheimer 106 de distinguer
davantage me manquera pas justement vers
la fin de sa vie était justement quand
j'étais jeune on appelait cela la mort
parce qu'il ce genre de symptômes
décrits reconnaissait plus ses enfants
et ceux qui en ont parlé récemment non
c'était pas un examen lucide jaune
démarre ce que tu es je pense qu'ils
manquaient de ces vaisseaux sanguins vos
dépenses parce que la white amants
passionnés qui pas plus facile à traiter
non plus
tu écoutes et des démences à date on n'a
pas réussi beaucoup plus alors quitte à
cordes le oui l'a entre les gagnants
ah ouais c'est des leçons d'une démence
à corps de louis qui souvent proches par
kingson mais ça doit être très difficile
quand même dédié sa vie à la recherche
d'une maladie qu'on ne connaît encore
ces pubs qu'on ne sait plus quoi penser
que c'est un positionnement même temps
le cerveau quand même fascinant fin
qu'on apprend quand même dont on
développe des idées qu'on fait quand
même des découvertes relativement
intéressante au jour deux traités ils
soient des fois je discutais avec avec
olivier lé tout faire machine - cela
j'ai guéri l'alzheimer chez la souris à
plusieurs plusieurs rues et chez l'homme
c'est un peu plus compliqué mais c'est
là qu'ils ont des approches comme ça
prend de la difficulté à les traduire
encore en discuter
quelques essais thérapeutiques chez la
maison quand même mais quand même gioda
d'apprendre comment fonctionnent ces
régions-là du cerveau quand même ça ça
nous a donné des avancées en imagerie
cérébrale maintenant comme elle de plus
en plus capables de dire ah oui ce
serait probablement démence de type
alzheimer
d'après la perfusion au niveau du
cerveau ça qu'on ne fait quand même des
avancées
le défi qui reste encore c'est une
approche thérapeutique plante qui peut
qui peut fonctionner mais je pense que
ça va arriver un de ces jours le cancer
était vu aussi comme impossible il ya
plusieurs formes de cancer maintenant
qu'ils deviennent des malades chroniques
la croatie quand ici quand même assez
bien les traités hors série d'épreuves
santé mentale comme la schizophrénie par
exemple est-ce que vous l'aimez par
exemple la bipolarité outils ce genre de
troubles es que ce qu'on a des réponses
à ceux d'été la provenance encore une
fois c'est mérité
et là il ya quand même eu quand même
beaucoup d' approche thérapeutique ni
aussi de psychothérapie par exemple sur
tout ce qui est malade et dépressive -6
anxiété sur soyaux quand même et
nationales thérapeutique qui quand même
assez vaste
la schizophrénie aussi la schizophrénie
à
guérit pas du tout le même pour
plusieurs personnes la phase aiguë là
c'est le jeune adulte les jeunes amants
tout ça dure certes est en pré sensé
moins dramatiques en termes de vision de
tous ces histoires leurs mois et il ya
quand même des approches thérapeutiques
aussi un des défis souvent dans cette
maladie là c'est que lorsque tu te sens
un petit peu lié bien lotis venu pour ça
que j'aime bien et là ça revient petit
peu mais on comprend quand même pas
parfaitement mais par exemple dans la
schizophrénie 6 1 et 1 euro transmetteur
dans ces rôles qui fonctionne mal c'est
la double main de ces mêmes que dans le
parkinson mais ce point même région du
cerveau pendant un code ne trouve dans
tout cas il ne passait mais à mai pour
la schizophrénie s'ils souhaitent
contrôler la dopamine dans certaines
régions du cerveau mais ça reste une
maladie difficile personne un peu comme
la zone rouge que certains points ce
qu'on appelle dans le jargon l'agent de
diagnostic d'exclusion fait là dessus
toi jeune femme - dames qui très souvent
pour toujours mais quand c'est souvent
fonctionne très bien et à l'école sont
des dix premiers de classe a va très
très bien pu groupe 16 ans 17 ans 18 ans
qu'est ce qui se passe à part ça
décroche kebab et là les parents
s'inquiètent qu'est ce qui se passe
c'est pas ça c'est pas ça c'est pas ça
fait maintenant tu dis en public
c'est probablement de schizophrénie
concerne diagnostic d'exclusion d'exclus
tous les ovaires et ça ça prend du temps
avant d'avoir ce diagnostic là et c'est
élisant les gens souffrent beaucoup et
là le lier entre les parrains et ils
enfants souvent très très très très dur
et période très très très difficile avec
ces deux maladies la schizophrénie pour
moi c'est une des plus difficiles des
maladies mentales les plus difficiles
mais bolaris t il pas simple non plus
aux dépressions se passer - mais avoir à
choisir le premier jamais mieux celle là
là quelle classe quelle loi inique et
iodée des personnes qui risquent quand
même assez bien
il avec une schizophrénie eu des prix
nobel gay qui est qui qui était
schizophrène lomé mais globalement c'est
une maladie qui est encore très
compliqué très souvent ya beaucoup mais
en toxicomanie aussi en décrochage a
entendu tes fesses que des maladies qui
est une nuit avec le je mets des
guillemets le jeune juge pas et je
connais rien mais est-ce que donc est ce
que ces maladies le on est déjà un peu
prédestiné à développer l'examen ou et
la schizophrénie par exemple ou pas
nécessairement les amarres pour ce
qu'ils ont très tôt la génétique cela et
tu vois tu va développer la maladie
relativement tôt dans notre antenne
quarantaine 50 m
mais ça c'est très rare déco très très
dur hard côté schizophrénie ya pas de
gêne aussi pénétrant qu'on appelle il ya
des maladies à caen par exemple d'autres
maladies neurologiques la maladie de
huntington
ouais ça c'est purement génétique la cie
peuvent te dire lorsque ta mère
lorsqu'elle était enceinte vont savoir
que bien que ces mails à des villages
accent c'est vraiment très très très
aride terre une maladie génétique très
pénétrantes que dans la schizophrénie
code génétique ou 6 [ __ ] 30e panoplie de
gênes fakir ça va donner une
susceptibilité et c'est ce qu'on a c'est
de voir c est ce qu on peut diminuer la
possibilité que se développe la
schizophrénie 25 30 ans plus tard avec
deux plaies de est un des éléments
pesant encore et encore des discussions
dans la communauté scientifique mais on
en a parlé quand même pas mal au québec
les jeunes surtout les jeunes des hommes
jeunes garçons je dorme le 15 à 14 15 16
ans le cannabis est déclenché à dix
donnes susceptibilité à la schizo
peut-être qu'à sortira jamais de toute
la vie mais on déclenche à pour être le
cannabis pourquoi plus le cannabis que
certaines autres drogues
plus ou moins certains encore la veille
quand même d'assez bonnes études là
dessus l'ex aussi c'est de dire à ces
jeunes le label faut faire un peu
attention il est très souvent sa part
répond comme cela ils de vue dans les
générations c'est oui mon mon père ou ma
mère ou la grand-mère est un peu
différente des autres fait finalement
que sera cette romance qui avait sa part
souvent mais c'est une génétique qui a
même qui est très très pénétrantes et
l'on pense de plus en plus qu'à
peut-être avec que dans le système
d'éducation
si on était capable d'offrir un support
adéquat on pourrait diminuer beaucoup
lyrisme développer ces maladies le plus
tard puis aux autos au tout début du
podcast vous avez mentionné crise
politique il a dans le fond cela comme
la manipulation génétique nama est ce
que est ce que ça pourrait être des
genres de choses comme ceux des
solutions ce genre de maladie le dal
fois dans le sens qu'ils sont capables
de devoir ou est-ce que ça se trouve le
modifier des jeux chez l'enfant après ce
jour pour ces malades il est un peu
compliqué beaucoup de gens mais pour
d'autres ça commence déjà dans certaines
formes de cancer
certaines formes de maladies cardiaques
des problèmes au niveau de la vision en
vieillissant que sa note peut guérir ça
avec crosse pas cette modification du
jamais vu peux-tu peut guérir le fait
que sa thérapie gêné dans ces cas-là
mais en général c'est juste un ou deux
jeunes qui sont impliqués pour gina
targuer d'en corriger à 25,30 en même
temps mais avec le développement des
technologies peut-être que ça pourrait
arriver dans le futur lors que tu peux
vraiment des ans corrigé davantage très
tôt et finalement tu peut protéger les
personnes contre développement de ce
genre de pesos a évolué au seuil a
inscrit ce père c'est quoi ces dix ans
environ que ça a été découvert comme
comme outil à partir en colonne à partir
de travail des bactéries de ces outils
là et va classer ce et puis ça c'est sûr
que là aussi d'exclusion de côté
directement à faire n'importe quoi parce
qu'on peut pas
ces mesures de choisy comme dd je suis
aussi est-ce qu'on attend la ville fait
interrompre ya vu des abus les quelques
chercheurs qui ont dépénalisé de scouts
et leurs portions du sud est
tu sais technologie là pour faire du
clonage et la borne ans et ça c'est
vraiment rézé interdit en effet que je
vois de basket-ball je vais mettre des
barrières du côté de l'éthique faut
vraiment s'assurer que les sociétés ont
des règles de ce côté là mais en même
temps il ya des possibilités quand même
très très bonne pour les personnes
aveugles par exemple ses fans de la cité
c'est peut-être pour c'était vraiment un
produit de la culture populaire qui qui
donne toujours un petit malaise quand
j'entends toutes ces choses le titre
justement comme on parle de thor le bdc
faille qu'on a regardé de la science
fiction au regard des qui dépeignent un
monde où est ce qu'il ya eu des abus de
ces technologies l'ofppt ses
connaissances le de façon poétique qui
amène se voir un dystopie combler tout
c'est peut-être pour ça qu'à chaque fois
j'étais un peu comme tout le temps au
matin c'est super optimiste cool mais
après c'est un genre de paradis ac prend
des bonnes balises de société parce que
même sans ces grands sites nouvelles
technologies la ré pendant la deuxième
guerre mondiale a eu quand même le des
approches quitté bouffe alors les deux
trouvé le super humaine
il y avait beaucoup de travaux de ce
côté là aussi il ya des peuples qui ont
souffert énormément de sadate pas
nécessairement juste parce que des
technologies plus modernes et des gens
qui voulait déjà faire ça y est très
très longtemps mais ça prend des bonnes
balises société c'est interdit
encore une fois qu'il est question
semaine puis séance
naturellement essentielle
je pense que le cerveau est un organe
fabuleux et si nous cécile et cherche
alcan de décider l'hémisphère droit
c'est ça le gaucher sentent qu'on a mis
sa part si lula le cerveau les sciences
sociales sciences humaines génie de
mathématiques ça votre temps on aura
beau organiser nos systèmes d'éducation
toute façon la satire date pas d'hier
c'est l'université a depuis depuis
bologne depuis mille ans mais on est
restés beaucoup là-dedans avec des silos
fait que maintenant c'est pas vraiment
le temps de se rapprocher un peu plus
tout ça est pour moi je dis très souvent
qu'un bon scientifique salubre un bon
niveau il faut créativité commun comme
un artiste
ils ont eu trop tendance mais le
chercheur dans un coin les scientifiques
d'un coin des artistes donnent à l'autre
comment trouver des façons de rapprocher
ces deux mondes là bas c'est vraiment
l'aspect de créativité dans des deux
camps sont les plus importants moi j'ai
toujours aimé étudiants là tu vois t'es
riche t'as ton expérience pour ce qui
est important foot sur hbo est ce que tu
vois pas quel symbole qu'est ce qui
aurait dû parce que rezaï topic est pas
là si tu es si ça marche toujours comme
tu penses tu sais pas de la bonne
science là il faut il faut vraiment
quelque chose qui ne comprend pas c'est
la poêle et la danse montmartre et cette
créativité là et l'on essaie de le faire
un petit peu avec la coved encore une
fois on a un programme cots bidart où le
désert tison marre des dix municipalités
soumettre des projets et là ils devaient
avoir des chercheurs des scientifiques
avec des artistes est faible
ce qu'ils ont fait les brouillons
produite dans public l'oxydation
vraiment fabuleux et ça vraiment d'en
faire davantage de changements de
programme pour remettre ces gens
d'expertisé leur ensemble
je pense être aimée attrait important
c'est quoi le domaine de recherche des
sciences d'innovation qui vous tout tout
tout domaines confondus le qui vous
fascine le plus m'étonne c'est peut-être
que on a déjà parlé en fait le pet
excellent des sujets qu on a déjà parlé
mais ce qui est vraiment quelque chose
qui vous dit as ce dans le futur
domaine cette recherche le cette
novation le ca c'est incroyable
j'essayais de comprendre un peu plus
l'ordinateur coincé à voir recommencer
quelque chose ça j'aimerais ça
éventuellement mieux comprendre tout ça
et l'hôtel l'autre bout se serait
peut-être plus lol génie génétique là
avec une technologie de type crise par
an c'est de comprendre un peu plus les
possibilités les défis de ce tas de ce
champ de technologies là ça c'est
quelque chose qui m'intéresserait
m'intéresserait enfin commencer la
saison est resté près du cerveau malgré
que c'était pas du tout là dedans mais
quand j'ai fait mes études de doctorat
je défends ma la maladie cardiaque qu'il
fait sur le cardio vasculaires et puis à
la fin du pillage du jura suffisamment
de chercheurs au canada qui connaît ce
système cardiovasculaire je voudrais
prendre le serbe pour tout le monde en
haut mais je connais j'y reviens tard
beauty aux états unis dans un
laboratoire pendant 13 mai c'est
fabuleux je pense que de ce côté là le
cerveau et à fait incroyable que je
resterai sûrement près de cherbourg
pensez-vous des technologies comme you
lie une des six compagnies dit le masque
qui est en train de 2 qui s'appelle
mirrorlink l'ekiden espèce de tv née un
jour d'un plat avec les calibrer
communiqué finalement après ce qu'on a
quand même plus besoin de seulement deux
téléphones intelligents tout serait un
plat de pensez vous qu'on va se rendre
le respect peut-être exactement l'homme
il ya déjà des exemples dans les
maladies neurologiques ou les problèmes
au niveau de la moelle épinière il ya
déjà un peu le d'interface homme-machine
on s'approche cyborg pour des gens à qui
on par exemple qui était paralysé qui
n'ont pas marché des poutrelles alors
maintenant contrôler tout ça avec leur
cerveau la mab avec des électrodes je
pense que c'était une rolex sa visée
premier en rien c'était pour les gens
qui sont paralysés de capable de femmes
marché des gens qui eux ils sont des
gens qui sont pris avec sa tétraplégie
compte rappeler gect être capable
d'offrir ce assez faible en asie en plus
le sud du pont en question de prendre
des tonnes de médicaments
c'est une question du téléthon
ton esprit temps cerveau nous faire
activer tout ça avec les et
microélectrodes est tout seul
exc c'est faible est-ce que ça va aller
beaucoup plus loin
les cyborgs et tout est interconnecté
comme les barques d'antan j'avais une
chaire de recherche des pistes et où
dans le monde mais il travaille sur des
autres tops et amener les ordinateurs
est en train de communiquer entre eux
dans un langage que l'aide avant que les
scientifiques comprenez pop qui ont
justice pour les gens qui nous écoutent
qui veulent rester à l'affût de tous
ceux qui veulent vous suivre qui veulent
qu'ils ont entendu le podcast qui
trippent comment on fait pour avoir plus
de ceux restés plus proche de la science
et comment on fait pour connaître les
nouvelles études comment on fait pour
réparer ce pont là qu'on parlait tout à
l'heure
entre le domaine la recherche et la
population jeu que nous on est on est
quand même assez actif laddh côté des
réseaux sociaux donc avec avec julien
jacques delaire nino l'aigle à tous qui
les citent le site scientifique enchères
tomber des nouvelles assez fréquemment
là dessus au niveau des fonds de
recherche du québec qu'à chaque mois on
de des capsules
on essaie d'expliquer un peu losc
certaines des charges certaines ont
découvert des chercheurs
il ya aussi les détecteurs de rumeurs
que me connaissez peut-être aussi leur
quiconque on publie beaucoup sur nos sur
nos réseaux si on jamais est ce que
c'est vrai qui rit on guérit l'alzheimer
cette semaine ça aussi la baule face
salle on sait beaucoup sur nos sites
d'écouté bien jour de 7 en français mais
aussi des sites de qualité le tout par
exemple côté santé le neige sont ensuite
offert où ces derniers sont ainsi de
très grande qualité qui essaie aussi de
vulgariser beaucoup
les résultats de recherche du coup dans
le domaine des sciences de vivre plus
large gueule nationals ont déçu aux
états unis où là aussi c'est plus les
technologies le génie les mathématiques
l'aide en sortir c'est d'aller vers dés
décide de qualité des sites renommés
ça peut pas dire que c'est le premier
site que ça si tu fais souvent c'est
pour les premiers que ça mais il faut au
moins aller vers le 3e 4e 5e 2 c'est
peut-être là qu'est la vérité plutôt que
juste d'avoir quelque chose qui est très
populaire au début et de suivent mais
par la suite d'interroger très souvent
d'endroits sur nos sites ont parlé de
telle équipe tel groupe de comptes de
pas ce gène et non plus contracter ses
jambes
s'ils répondent pas aux mains des
contacts deuxième fois on pleure on peut
aider de ce côté là aussi des fois tu
attaques un chiffre à l'appel puisque
ben alors traité contacté par telle
personne qui devrait répondre ça fait ça
bouge un peu
on va définitivement refusé notre
contact avec votre équipe
un énorme merci c'était extrêmement
pertinent super agréable c'est un
plaisir merci beaucoup merci r on peut
joindre en amenant demandé pardon à
d'autres toute vie d'autrui tu cherches
un tout à fait marseillais merci encore
une fois